[موسيقى]
خففت الولايات المتحدة مؤقتًا القيود
المفروضة على منتجات هواوي بعد
أن أدرجت إدارة ترامب الشركة الصينية في القائمة السوداء
الأسبوع الماضي ، قال وزير
التجارة الأمريكي إنه يهدف إلى منح
مشغلي الاتصالات الذين يعتمدون على
معدات Huawei وقتًا لإجراء ترتيبات أخرى ،
وهو المزود الوحيد
للشبكات  معدات للعديد من
مزودي الإنترنت الريفيين الأمريكيين الذين يقولون إن
الأمر سيستغرق وقتًا أو ربما من المستحيل
استبدال سبب ظهور التكنولوجيا دائمًا بعد أن
قالت Google إنها تقيد طرق
الوصول إلى نظام التشغيل Android الخاص بها
، حيث ينضم إلينا مراسل الأعمال شري فام
مباشرة من هونج كونج ننتظر
الرد من Huawei ، نحن في انتظار
الرد من الردهة ، لكن Google
قد أصدرت بيانًا اليوم
يشير إلى أن هذا التأجيل من
وزارة التجارة سيؤثر أيضًا
على كيفية قيامهم
بخدمة هواتف Huawei وكذلك
قول Google اليوم.  الهواتف محدثة
وآمنة في مصلحة الجميع
وهذا مؤقت
يسمح لنا الترخيص ary بمواصلة تقديم
تحديثات البرامج وتصحيحات الأمان
للنماذج الحالية لمدة 90 يومًا القادمة الآن ، يقول
ويلبر روس بالطبع أن هذا
الترخيص كان لمدة 90 يومًا وكان من
المفترض حقًا أن يكون وسيلة للمساعدة كما
تقول الشبكات الريفية  في الولايات
المتحدة لمواصلة خدمة
عملائها ، لكن هذا سيساعد
Google قليلاً
وسيساعد أيضًا Huawei ، لكن الكلمة الأساسية في هذا
البيان كانت الهاتف المحمول الحالي ،
فماذا يعني هذا بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين لديهم
هواتف huawei بالفعل أو  التفكير في
شراء واحدة جيدًا ، فهذا يعني أنه
إذا كان لديك هاتف huawei الآن
، فستستمر في الوصول إلى المجموعة الكاملة
من خدمات Google ونظام Google
البيئي وستحصل على
تصحيحات الأمان والتحديثات على
نظام التشغيل Android ولكن إذا كنت
تفكر في شراء هاتف المدخل
في المستقبل من المحتمل ألا يتمكن هذا الهاتف من
الوصول إلى نظام Google البيئي
لأن Google يجب أن تمتثل لهذا الأمر
لنا  الحظر وهذا أكثر من مجرد
فقدان الوصول إلى التطبيقات الشائعة مثل
YouTube و Gmail ، ومن المحتمل أيضًا أن
تفقد وظائف التطبيقات مثل
uber أو التسليم
لأن تطبيقات الطرف الثالث تعتمد على
خدمات Google مثل خرائط Google لتعمل
بشكل صحيح وأنت تعرف محللاً  لقد
تحدثت لأوضح الأمر بإيجاز حقًا ،
فقال إنه بدون الوصول إلى تلك الخدمات ،
فإن هاتف huawei هو عبارة عن لبنة وعمل
هاتف ذكي في الردهة ميت في المياه
الخلفية